hi I'm Timothy ma from Hong Kong and I
came from the organization cause also
senior citizen home safety association
which is a hundred percent
self-financing organization and we had
the biggest source enterprise in Hong
Kong serving 80,000 people my question
is about increasing East Asia's reached
resilience and how can I Asia employees
addition to possible future disasters I
think as East Asia as a share that
nearly half of the total population the
globe and we have to have higher
awareness and also precautions on what
will be happen and branded and
unexpectedly that's called natural
disasters like flooding lie epidemics
like Earth or even tsunami so what we
need to do is to have a united system to
detect and also pre-announced what the
disaster will be coming that means we
have to have a very good alert system
that join operated by the whole Asia
region to work together secondly we also
have to practice the so-called disaster
preparedness I strategies that means
helping the people having a government
the senior officials to be assertive and
also sensitive to what will be hampered
in and also thirdly I think the people
also should practice the way how to run
away from the disaster and also to
improve and also enhance the elected
pneus towards the disasters and so um a
very viable other system should be in
place and then a very well prepare a
comprehensive these aspirin essers
strategies and policies should be in
place and thirdly we also have a very
immediate response and relief project
that whenever there is any disaster
having any one of the country the entire
region can help em for subtle
to care the people that affected by the
disaster